[Music]
okay everybody so this is my review of
dexter new blood episode 9 the
penultimate episode titled the family
business to address the elephant in the
room the reason i look like i just
robbed a bank and i have this hat on is
because
i am currently sick getting better not
100 yet and i don't want to look like
george costanza because i wasn't able to
get my head shaved this week because i
don't want to get anybody sick so
please forgive the appearance and
forgive the nasally voice i totally
understand if you want to just do
subtitles this week i get it i would do
the same and everyone obviously please
stay safe out there it is crazy out
there right now so definitely stay safe
okay so let's talk about this crazy
crazy episode of dexter so
like we keep talking about and again
caught on by youtube commenters early
how awesome it is that the title
sequence of dexter new blood keeps
filling up with blood we see how close
it is to filling up the blood here and
just going with the blood theme what
really worked in this episode is just
having this blood moon and
that blood moon usually symbolizes the
beginning of end of times so that's
really scary where you look at where
we're at in this episode and also
visually looks great when we see it when
harrison's sitting outside in the snow
later in the episode because
it looks like the title credits where
the moon's almost full with blood and
thematically what this episode really
really leans into
is the whole justification for what
dexter does and
this comparison like they joke about
many times with batman and vigilantism
and how
that all relates and what he really is
and it really did feel like batman and
robin now watching this with harrison
coming into the fold and i was surprised
how well and enjoyable it worked having
the two of them do this together and i
didn't think that would be that
interesting or maybe just would just be
too far-fetched but no i was sitting
there watching it and going like i could
watch more of this
than just doing stuff together and being
a tag team i really enjoyed it but i
thought it was just the right amount of
flashback here to maybe even catch up
people who didn't even watch the
original series to really get in the
mind of dexter's way of things with this
wiggle story and i love that it was nice
to see dexter in miami again in that
time and having it really lean into the
original score here from the show which
i loved and you know with the wiggles
thing i like the narrations i had in
this like guilty people slip through the
cracks every day you can't count on the
justice system and it works that he
breaks the fourth wall a lot here
because it's not a gimmick when you have
it that he's actually explaining the
story to harrison the same time so it
was justified and worked well
did the guy who played wiggles the clown
have to do joaquin phoenix joker
impression and have the exact mirror
shot no i thought that was a little much
i mean it was just too similar it kind
of actually took me out of it for a
second i know that's a nitpick but
sometimes i get annoyed like someone's
idea like let's just make them look like
the recent clown i saw you know just
make it a little different it's too
similar but what really worked for this
episode on its own was that dexter
showing harrison the code but it's only
coming and revealing it little by little
and
it's making you on as you see because
you're waiting for him to you know drop
the big hammer that he's killing these
people so they did a good job of getting
to that and doing it at a great rhythm
where it wasn't too fast but it wasn't
too slow either and having it worked so
well the best that's worked yet in the
show with deb the moments they put deb
in were perfect to have it kind of be
that other side that other voice in
dexter's head like one of the lines i
love in the beginning you tell harrison
you kill people there's no going back
and one of the strongest moments in the
episode of the season
was when dexter fights back with deb
here because she brings up harrison
going to therapy
institutionalize even prison and that's
our dexter snaps and he's like whose
side are you on i thought that was great
and even the part two where she brings
up how he saw his mom be chopped up and
now he chops up bodies but he's like
well harrison has a straight razor now
like trinity so it's like again keeping
a good theme of the father like son
going on throughout this episode but
again every scene with deb
really fit and the timing was excellent
of where they put her in and again going
back to even the prison moment i just
saw michael c hall's performance there
was great like to let that anger come
out in dexter which we rarely see and
just see him snap like that and hit a
sore spot was really something and it
really makes you think about just
what would you do and how we even
address people even maybe at a young age
we're talking about urges to do bad
things and how we handle that and where
do they go where do they get help that
kind of thing so i think it really gets
you thinking which is good also just
there's some great humorous moments here
with dexter even just his face when he's
watching harrison open up the gun was
hysterical and keep in mind i thought
that had to be important that harrison
yes first character was already showing
aggression how quickly he was just
taking use of that gun without dexter's
help but i think it's going to be
important how well harrison is with the
gun and how he has a good shot that
might come back in the finale we'll see
but it's such a great performance by
michael c hall here too because
he's doing such a good job at holding
back
letting something out and he's like got
that feeling we have as an audience like
come on harrison just say it you know
like even when he's like ask me what the
plan is ask me if you can help i thought
those moments were just so well done by
moxie mexico and it's such a
masterful performance that not many
people could do and it's proxy jack
alcott who's playing harrison too
keeping up with him and doing an amazing
job as well and you knew when dexter had
that narration a successful christmas
surrounded by family when he's at
angela's place and kurt just right on
cue shows up that was crazy
and you realize too at this moment that
kurt dropped in that mailbox his dagger
that's going to be from the grave with
the evidence about dexter
killing matt
and it makes you just realize that
dexter's so focused on this relationship
with harrison what's going on with
harrison he's not been realizing that
angela is literally
so close
to catching him as a bay harbor butcher
but also right there
kurt literally had that in the mailbox
and
they're so focused on just going and
getting kurt uh so it's just crazy how
that they did that so well that little
slip up now the score really stood out
to me and just i loved the visual of
like this hail that was happening
when
harrison and dexter were just sitting on
the back of his pickup truck and
harrison is really opening up now about
his fantasies of killing the trinity
killer with his own razor and that
perfect moment like i'm saying the
timing of just showing deb there looking
at dexter was perfect just at home or
dexter's like just wants to say all of
it and we get those great fan moments i
think everyone can enjoy when he's
telling harrison like don't get caught
and just exciting to see him teach him
the code when harrison's ready to run
over to kurt
and again to the suspense and pacing of
the episode worked really well too is
having dex and harrison going to kurtz
at the same time kurt is at dexter's and
torching this place up and while this is
all happening angela's just getting
closer and closer and again proxy julia
jones here just crushing it with a lot
of facial
acting and yeah where the hell is the
billionaire i mean
is that just a plot line they just
dropped completely with this guy i don't
know what happened maybe
he might come back as like a
post-credits scene for the finale or so
maybe he'll be the next villain who
knows i mean
i i don't know that's interesting so now
it's crazy when they get to kurt's
trophy room and
just some pure horror and it was shot
really well the lights coming on as each
section of this trophy room is revealed
and all these women and we get the big
reveal that molly was already killed by
kurt which a lot of people predicted
last week so nice call on that
i think we might actually get maybe a
scene of that when he was with molly uh
for the finale i feel like they might
show a little flashback because i still
feel like there needs to be something
else with molly here of her just
shown here i don't i don't know why my
gut's telling me that but it does feel
like something is missing and that just
seeing her dead like that
did feel a little flat in a sense but
what it does do it leads to
the best moment of the episode when
harrison is putting all together and
he's like you killed wiggles didn't you
and debs literally like don't and the
moment when dexter reveals that yes he
did and that he also killed arthur
mitchell trinity for what he did to your
mother wow that was incredible it just
put a smile to your face and the score
again just perfect here still my
favorite narration of dexter humor wise
of the season was when i should just
kill you for the wallpaper and a couple
episodes back but here he has some good
moments where harrison's like how many
times have you done this and he's like a
lot and he goes how many and the
narration goes go bigger go home and he
tells them the amount and harrison goes
that means you've saved thousands of
innocent people and the way he says in
his head that's right like that was so
funny to me it was just perfect but what
was happening kurt's on the table and
kurt's explaining his trauma to them
he's like i protected these women i
preserved them kept them safe forever
it's a really well written villain in
that sense too and exactly why he does
this ritual he does but you see dex
brings up you love the power you had
over them the hunt
and
you know you gotta love when writing's
like this where there's subtext here
that it's also
kind of in its own sense talking about
dexter and that relation him and kurt
have but this is where kurt brings up to
harrison which definitely still spooked
harrison a bit that dexter didn't even
mention that he killed matt
and
dexter quickly explains matt fit the
code and what a haunting moment they had
visually here when dex says to kurt that
when matt was on his table he blamed his
father too and he says like father like
son they perfectly time it with the rack
focus shot between dexter and harrison i
thought that was great directing and
cinematography and this will lead to
when harrison starts bugging out when
that blood's dripping and it triggers
the moment that happened with rita and
this is where it wasn't as smooth
sailing for decks too so that's gonna be
interesting because you see the concern
in deck space that harrison was going
through all this fine and now he's
bugging out this got him so it leads to
that visual i talked about the blood
moon um and it makes you question where
harrison's even just gonna be his head
at the next episode and this will end
now where they go back to the house and
angela is just at this point where she
just sounds like she's interrogating
dexter like this is like crazy how this
is all happening and then her to find
again the dagger from the grave from
kirk caldwell with the matte screws in
the envelope was insane jim lindsey
killed matt caldwell it says so wow this
so much was the process here i'm
definitely giving this one a 9.6 i think
it lived up to the hype that has been
built up for the end of this season
and it really just makes you like oh my
god like what are we gonna see in this
finale i think the big mystery about it
too is there's no clear answer still
people will say different things but
there still isn't in stone like this is
the final season again like this is
gonna be the final episode of dexter
ever you don't know that i mean it does
so well for showtime so
they might lead this to like we said a
harrison show will they kill dexter will
they just have them arrested or if
they're going to keep the story going
are they just have them go on the run
again when angela finds us out or i've
seen the theories that new blood with it
filling up in the titles doesn't just
meet harrison but it also means angela
that maybe there is a game here where
angela sees all these women were killed
by cart and
this makes her see how there is no
justice in the system she thought there
was so maybe we'll kind of get her to
convinced by dexter and harrison we'll
see
i'm curious if that can happen on one
episode maybe that's something if they
do do a second season it will lead to
that with angela and that she's on the
hunt for dexter maybe so it's exciting
and
i'm pumped up uh let me know your
theories and what you thought exactly
this episode and appreciate all you guys
so i can't wait to see you finale and
please follow me at steve varney's show
on twitter instagram and tick tock for
more of me and if you really want to do
here i appreciate you becoming a member
today it helps me in so many ways and
help me do this full time one day and
you'll get special perks as well and
i'll see you next week